hi my name is Mila Kunis and I feel
irrelevant about being gone all right
irrelevant yes because you have so many
friends no I don't actually you have so
many friends I don't do you really think
I do because I don't I have a lot of
acquaintances everyone claims to be your
friend Cody the amount of times I've
heard a cone is my friend
did they say that my friend he's my
friend Dakota's my good friend he's my
friend are you down south a lot I think
you said uh what did you what was last
time indifferent yeah so um we've gone
from indifference well sometimes it
takes you a while to text me back oh you
know what I'm saying that's true so I
feel like there's something we can work
on we can build off of this we had a
text thing going recently because I saw
BJ Novak's movie yeah Vengeance which is
fantastic and I texted you to just tell
Ashton that I thought he killed it in
that movie he was so so good yeah and
then we start going back and forth and
you know and then you just left me I
just I go you ghosted me yeah
he goes with you but then I went around
yelling at people I just ghosted Mila
Kunis Isn't that cool
doesn't that make me a cool person no
one thought that it was cool no okay
I'll pay you uh a compliment you are one
of the nicest and most real people I've
met that's in this business you may
actually have the top slot really yes
seriously since the day I met Mila years
ago when you came to the show and then I
think we chatted afterwards about play
you know where you thought you'd get
like the cheapest t-shirts
and and I sure I swear to God there's a
saying in Show Business that well that
person went through the machine yeah
you've heard that saying we're like
people get started and I saw it so many
times on my show and I won't name names
but I saw people come up when they were
really young young and they were guest
on the show and they had just hit and
they were so full of life and then the
next time I saw them like a year later
no they were cautious they kind of
looked different yeah they publicists
had been working on them and it's called
going through the machine and it can
sometimes be sort of a sad experience
and
I I swear to God you have never changed
and even today I'm outside when you pull
up here at the podcast studio and you've
got uh your food and you're like I said
okay if I eat my food and then you start
chatting about your vacation and you're
talking to everybody in the office and
that is rare oh it is that's sad but I
think I got really lucky I really do I I
never was screwed up I did dumb things
like don't get me wrong but I think that
I came up in a time before social media
and so when I was trying to call it like
1920 was the beginning of Perez Hilton
and I acquaint a lot of this going
through the machine of like being
cautious and now everybody has to worry
about what they say how they say what
they look because everything is so
documented I didn't have that right and
so I was still able to be lazy for the
lack of it like I didn't have to try to
be anything other than myself because it
wasn't being documented anywhere and I I
really I feel really bad for
anyone who's coming up now who's like 16
15 even whatever to like 25 because it's
such a growing period in your life and
to have that be blasted and now with
this idea that we are holding people
responsible for what they said 10 years
ago yeah yeah none of that I mean you
know you can't do this anyways it's uh I
got very lucky and I have awesome
parents I don't think I ever had a crazy
period but yeah if I was a known person
when I was 15 there would have been a
lot of you know Conan buying acne cream
yeah but also like
acne cream
you would never steal I wouldn't I know
but my assistant that's why you have one
yeah
um I steal but don't you think that
that's what if this is a whole other
podcast to unravel I just need to
clarify I don't steal anymore
I did I used to have like a shoplifting
thrill like what like like little
bracelets from Express or a headband
from Urban outfit just to be like I did
it yeah yeah just for the thrill yeah
we've actually wanted to do a remote
where I make her go back to all the
stores that she stole from and and
confess and return the merchandise which
I think would be that thing would go
viral yeah if we put that out there but
you um you have twin boys now yeah who
are a year old yeah and there's always
the the worry that they will grow up
knowing their mother is the criminal she
is so you bring it up all the time so
they're gonna know regardless she
brought her kids to the studio the other
day Mikey and Charlie in beautiful
one-year-old boys and I just am playing
with them and shouting your mother's
stolen yeah
so often I hardly believe it
it did happen yeah that makes sense I'm
a terrible person very on brand Conan I
do think I do think even if you had
grown up in this age you'd have figured
it out because I I you just have that
quality of your always yourself yeah
that is that's a gift and I think in
this town that's such an asset to just
know who you are you know who you are
yeah and you know what's important to
you yeah so yes you did a lot of crazy
things when you were 15. I mean crazy I
was still in comparison to other
children I was a very good kid like I
worked so I had responsibility so you
can only be so crazy or I wouldn't have
a job and I loved what I did it says
here you flew cocaine into Miami
that was that was different that was
just me myself
I know it's a job
made yeah hundreds of thousands of
dollars that was experimental
can you imagine if I ever did What Would
I I've never done hardcore drugs it's
just no me neither no me neither
everybody thought I did when I was a
teenager they really every time I went
out to a club and I used to go to like
clubs I didn't drink I mean I would have
like if someone snuck me like a vodka
soda I'd have a couple sips but I was
responsible because I knew I had to
drive home
but everybody would go to the bathroom
and they'd be like you you got some and
I was like oh do you need like a tampon
like
and they were like you know blah blah I
was like I I'm so sorry I kept
apologizing I'm so sorry I don't do that
yeah my whole life and no one yeah you
think I've mentioned this before but in
college I didn't do anything and I
walked into a room once and it was
a scene out of like Pretty in Pink where
the bad guys are all wearing white
tuxedos white tuxedo jackets but I
walked into a room and it's like three
guys in white tuxedo jackets with their
ties undone and they were cutting up
lines and they were like hey man you
want some coke and I said hmm my father
is a doctor
he says it's
interrupts the heart rhythm oh my God
they looked at me and I went it
interferes with the neural signals you
know what a nerd I am and I want to
pound dude I know trust me trust me I
gave him a lecture on interrupting the
heart rhythm